während die abgeordneten darüber jetzt
noch entscheiden schauen wir schon mal
auf die nächsten tagesordnungspunkt da
geht es um eine verlängerung der
sonderregelung beim kurzarbeitergeld in
der pandemie wurde ist ja wurden dort
bestimmte sonderregeln eingeführt dass
zum beispiel
das kurzarbeitergeld erhöht wird ab dem
vierten bezugsmonat bekommen diejenigen
die dieses kurzarbeitergeld bekommen 70
prozent des nettolohns ab dem siebten
monat 80 prozent das ist mehr als
normalerweise aber eben in der pandemie
hatte regierung das beschlossen dass die
person jetzt mehr kriegen und wenn wir
uns mal die zahlen anschauen dann sieht
man wie viel mehr personen
kurzarbeitergeld bekommen haben im
februar 20 20
184.000 personen kurzarbeitergeld
bekommen und wenn wir das mal
vergleichen im april 2020 also zwei
monate später haben tatsächlich sechs
millionen personen kurzarbeitergeld
bekommen mittlerweile ist die zahl
zurückgegangen aber es gibt immer noch
viele menschen die darauf mit angewiesen
sind und deswegen haben hier die
koalitionsfraktionen einen gesetzentwurf
eingereicht dass eben diese
sonderregelung dass man mehr geld
bekommt um drei monate noch mal
verlängert wird bis zum 30 juni darüber
wird hier jetzt gleich diskutiert und
auch dann abgestimmt zu diesem
gesetzentwurf gibt es auch einen
entschließungsantrag der linksfraktion
auch david hier diskutiert denn auch
wenn das
von der linksfraktion
erst einmal
gutgeheißen wird dass diese regelung
verlängert wird fordert die
linksfraktion dass das kurzarbeitergeld
und nochmal erhöht wird auf nämlich 90
prozent des nettolohns also bis zur
person hier nochmal mehr bekommen der
erste redner in dieser debatte ist dann
auch bundesarbeitsminister hubertus heil
den haben wir hier auch schon gesehen
ist jetzt auch wieder im bild der hier
natürlich diesen gesetzentwurf der
fraktionen verteidigen wird und für die
zustimmung für die abstimmung werben
wird jetzt wechseln noch einmal die
abgeordneten dem platz und dann kann es
hier auch gleich in der debatte losgehen
reise gehen würde ich gern das wort
geben an den bundesminister hubertus
heil zur einbringen
[Applaus]
präsidentin meine damen und herren vor
ziemlich genau zwei jahren habe ich an
diesem rednerpult anbeginn der korona
krise deutlich für die damalige
bundesregierung das gilt aber auch für
die heutige bundesregierung gemacht was
unser ziel am arbeitsmarkt ist unser
ziel ist es durch diese corona krise die
tiefste gesundheitskrise aber auch die
tiefste wirtschaftskrise unserer
generation den deutschen arbeitsmarkt
stabil und robust zu bringen und ich
kann feststellen vieles hat nicht
geklappt und dieser pandemie aber es ist
mit kleinen kräften gelungen den
deutschen arbeitsmarkt vor allen dingen
mit dem instrument der kurzarbeit stabil
zu halten die kurzarbeit war und ist die
stabilste brücke über ein tiefes
wirtschaftliches tal und ich bin dankbar
dass das parlament diese region
habe das an anderer stelle auch erwähnt
ich war vor einem jahr eingeladen
digital muss man leider sagen in amerika
ein arbeit wird ein austausch mit
wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern über krisen reaktionen
in amerika und den usa auf der einen
seite in deutschland auf der anderen
seite am arbeitsmarkt und ich habe
festgestellt dass der begriff wird
kurzarbeit inzwischen im
angelsächsischen raum einen lehnen wort
geworden ist
ähnlich wie das schöne deutsche worte
kindergarten und es steht als chiffre
für gutes krisenmanagement kurzarbeit
meine damen und herren hilft uns zum
einen arbeitsplätze zu sichern wir haben
in der korona krise über drei millionen
arbeitsplätze gesichert wir hatten
insgesamt acht millionen anträge zur
kurzarbeit es hilft aber auch
volkswirtschaft die
gesamtwirtschaftliche nachfrage zu
stabilisieren aber es hilft auch
unternehmen jetzt nach der krise mit
fachkräften an bord wieder durchstarten
zu können deshalb soll ich an dieser
stelle das dürfen wir nie vergessen es
war nicht nur wirtschaftshilfen sondern
es war der deutsche sozialstaat der
mitgeholfen hat dieses land stabil durch
diese schwierigen zeiten suchen
und wir haben eine damen und herren
kurzarbeit war und ist für unseren
sozialstaat sehr sehr teuer wir hatten
damit in der krise 26 milliarden euro
rücklagen bei der bundesagentur für
arbeit aus den guten zeiten wir haben
sie voll eingesetzt wir haben dann mit
steuermitteln nachgeholfen damit die
bundesagentur für arbeit stets
handlungsfähig ist ich sage ihnen aber
auch deutlich in solchen krisen muss man
unterscheiden kurzarbeit verteuert aber
die rückkehr von massenarbeitslosigkeit
zuzulassen wäre für deutschland
wirtschaftlich und sozial viel viel
teurer gewesen deshalb war das der
richtige weg und wir setzen ihn heute
vor
will aber auch für die bundesregierung
erklären dass unser ziel nicht erst
kurzarbeit vor er war sondern wir bauen
brücken und wollen das andere ufer
erreichen wir haben die hoffnung dass
wir im sommer in einer anderen situation
ist aber wir haben nach wie vor branchen
die schwer getroffen sind vor allen
dingen veranstaltungs gewerbe im
messebau in der gastronomie und diese
unternehmen brauchen die beschäftigten
brauchen jetzt die kurzarbeit im
industriellen bereich haben wir auch mit
problemen hin und wieder zu tun obwohl
die industrie sehr sehr gut läuft
stichwort lieferketten problem also
deshalb bin ich dankbar dass dieser
deutsche bundestag heute die brücke
weiter verlängert ich bin übrigens auch
der opposition der vernünftigen
opposition dankbar dass sie der
fristverkürzung zu bestimmt hat und
offensichtlich heute auch mitmachen will
liebe kolleginnen kollegen aber es ist
wichtig dass wir diesen weg gehen im
einzelnen wir verlängern jetzt auch noch
mal die bezugsdauer von 24 auf 28 monate
weil wenn man zurück rechnet 24 monate
seit beginn der krise für viele
beschäftigten sonst zu einer
abbruchkante geführt haben und wir haben
die hoffnung dass wir im sommer in einer
besseren situation sind wir verlängern
die sogenannte treppe für diejenigen die
ganz lange drin sind und aufgrund der
tatsache dass in vielen bereichen keine
aufschläge gezahlt werden 60 oder 67
familien oft die geringverdiener sind
ziemlich harte nummer sind und deshalb
ist es richtig dass wir dafür sorgen
dass für diejenigen die lange drin sind
es auch ein puffer gibt bis hin zu 80 87
prozent meine damen und herren richtig
ist auch dass wir
eine verordnungsermächtigung gewünscht
haben und ich bin dem parlament sehr
dankbar dass sie das unterstützen und im
fall der fälle dass im sommer nicht gut
läuft aus welchen gründen auch immer wir
haben ja eine unkalkulierbare pandemie
auch kurzfristig noch reagieren zu
können ich hoffe allerdings dass wir
davon nicht gebrauch machen müssen ich
will dass dann auch sagen weil wir haben
einen schritt gemacht er in einigen
bereichen kritisiert wurde wir sind mit
dem sozialversicherungsbeiträge schon
zum ersten januar von 100 auf 50 prozent
runter und wir gehen jetzt von 50 auf
null ich halte das auch für vertretbar
zumal wir wirtschaftshilfen haben auch
aus dem bereich des kollegen habeck und
weil übrigens man sich 50 prozent holen
kann wenn man denn als unternehmen
kurzarbeit mit qualifizierung und
weiterbildung verknüpfen kann und ich
will auch sagen wir müssen auf die kasse
ein bisschen gucken denn die
bundesagentur für arbeit muss rücklagen
aufbauen für spätere krisensituationen
und für die großen aufgaben der
transformation in bezug auf die
qualifizierung zu nehmen
aber sehr dankbar dass sie diesen weg
heute gehen auch mit fristverkürzung sie
helfen damit vielen beschäftigten in
deutschland sie helfen unternehmen und
bei allem was nicht läuft wir können in
deutschland vielleicht auch mal stolz
sein auf die dinge die funktionieren die
kurzarbeit hat funktioniert dass es
nicht allein das verdienst der
bundesregierung oder meines ministeriums
oder dieses parlaments sondern es ist
vor allen dingen das verdienst der
fleißigen kolleginnen kollegen der
bundesagentur für arbeit die das
vorbildlich umgesetzt haben die ganze
zeit deshalb gilt mein gruß den
mitarbeiterin mitarbeitern in den
jobcentern und bundesagentur für arbeit
die deutschland wirklich durch diese
krise geholfen haben herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
soweit also der leitung von
bundesarbeitsminister hubertus heil auf
ihn folgten stephan stracke der sprecher
für arbeit und soziales der
unionsfraktion
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
auch in der gegenwärtigen lage der
pandemie ist die der vereinfachte zugang
zur kurzarbeit über den 31 märz hinaus
notwendig und auch ohne zweifel richtig
und der fristverkürzung bitte minister
sind wir natürlich gerne nachgekommen
wie unterstützen als oppositionsfraktion
immer dort wo es notwendig ist aber
erlauben sie mir ein bisschen hat es
mich doch erstaunt die mangelnde umsicht
und vorausschau weil der datum des 31
märz war doch allseits in diesem bereich
tatsächlich bekannt dass die
gegenwärtigen regelungen hier auslaufen
aber entscheidend ist das was sie
vorlägen und das was sie vorliegen ist
nicht ausreichend um beschäftigung zu
sichern und damit auch die unternehmen
in den kurzarbeitenden branchen in ihrem
mit ihren fachkräften halten zu können
ich fordere sie aufbessern sie nach und
verlängern sie für drei monate die
bisherigen regelungen für den hälfte
ersatz der sozialversicherungsbeiträge
und beziehen sie auch die zeitarbeit in
die regelung zur kurzarbeit mit ein
die dauer der pandemie und die damit
verbundenen einschränkungen haben viele
branchen finanziell belastet man ist der
harz erwähnt besonders hotel und
gaststättenbereich der einzelhandel dass
die veranstaltungswirtschaft der
messebau insbesondere auch das
verarbeitende gewerbe hat zum teil
probleme was lieferengpässe angeht und
in diesen branchen an diesen betrieben
sind die rücklagen und die liquidität
vielfach aufgebraucht und das stellen
sie ja selber fest beispielsweise in
ihrer begründung hinsichtlich der
eilbedürftigkeit ich darf zitieren es
gibt eine größere zahl von betrieben die
seit beginn der pandemie märz 2020
kurzarbeit beziehen und bei denen die
maximale bezugsdauer ende februar 2022
ausläuft aufgrund der dauer der pandemie
ist davon auszugehen dass diese betriebe
über keine ausreichende
liquiditätsreserven mehr verfügen die
betriebe sind also auf eine nahtlose
bewilligung von kurzarbeitergeld
angewiesen zitat ende und das bedeutet
natürlich auch die weitere erstattung
der sozialversicherungsbeiträge in höhe
von 50 prozent wenn keine ausreichende
liquidität vorhanden ist dann ist das
der notwendige weitere sprit schritt sie
springen zu kurz und gefährden auch den
letzten meter der hoffentlich endenden
pandemie ohne not arbeitsplätze das ist
aus unserer sicht der falsche weg den
sie an dieser stelle hier beschreiten
und die sachverständigenanhörung hat ja
ein ganz klares und eindeutiges ergebnis
in diesem bereich gezeigt unisono
wirtschaft und gewerkschaften sehen es
als notwendig an dass hier auch die
beiträge weiterhin erstattet werden
folgen sie dem rat der sachverständigen
und tun sie das richtige und auch der
hinweis auf die qualifizierung die der
minister getan hat ja natürlich schon
richtig qualifizierung ist überall gut
aber auch qualifizierung kostet geld und
wenn man sie ernst nehmen will in ihrer
argumentation was die liquidität angeht
dann funktioniert es nicht und dann ist
es auch kein praxistaugliches
instrumentarium das angenommen wird von
der praxis auch darauf haben die
sachverständigen
einstimmig hingewiesen also das
instrument der qualifizierung ist kein
praxistaugliches mittel zur
beschäftigungssicherung in der
gegenwärtigen lage und deswegen ist auch
der hinweis zu kurz gesprungen in diesem
bereich und auch was die aussicht auf
öffnung schritte angeht seien an der
stelle nur erwähnt auch das wird
natürlich
verbesserungen bringen aber bis die es
ankommt in den betroffenen betriebe
denken sie beispielsweise an den
messebau dauert dies doch wirklich
ziemlich lange und es ist vor allem auch
nicht nachvollziehbar warum sie die
zeitarbeitskräfte nicht den zugang zur
kurzarbeit gewähren beschäftigte in der
zeitarbeit sind keine beschäftigten
zweiter klasse auch sie haben es
verdient hier wie andere gleich mehr zu
werden und der deutsche
gewerkschaftsbund hat dies auch klar und
deutlich zum ausdruck gebracht und das
sollte für sie gerade von der spd
umsetzungs auftrag sein tun sie das
richtige und verändern sie das was not
tut nämlich richtige einbeziehung der
sozialversicherungsbeiträge und
natürlich die ein beziehungskiller
zeitgleich sauer reicht sonstwas
abziehen das gerade noch in gedanken
[Applaus]
zu ihrer ersten rede hat jetzt die
kollegin tina winkelmann das wort für
bündnis 90/die
jetzt im ausschuss für arbeit und
soziales
[Applaus]
sie denke sehr geehrte kolleginnen und
kollegen wir folgen dem rat der
sachverständigen und deswegen verlängern
wird es ist freitag und deshalb passt es
hervorragend dass wir heute über dieses
thema sprechen wir wissen doch alle was
es heißt dass freitag es ist wochenende
wissen sie noch hier sind nach einer
arbeitswoche auf veranstaltungen liegen
haben die klubs ein kurztrip übers
wochenende
wir kommen abschalten energie tanken und
freuten uns die ganze woche auf ein
konzert ein theaterstück auf kultur auf
veranstaltungen auf einen schafkopf auf
gastlichkeit für viele ging die arbeit
dann erst richtig los und jetzt immer im
gastgewerbe im gastgewerbe und in der
veranstaltungsbranche viele wichtige
jobs hängen genau hier dran und die
hätten wir mit der kurzarbeit die kultur
gehören
[Applaus]
die kultur will ihren hunger nach
wirkung stehen und wir hunger nach
kultur hier braucht als
arbeitsplatzsicherung
sehr geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen
die die zeit reicht liebe nicht aus um
auf alle bereiche explizit einzugehen
die unsere hilfe brauchen und von uns
durch die verlängerung des
kurzarbeitergeldes auch bekommen einen
wichtigen bereich will und muss ich aber
nennen es ist die pflege denn mit der
verlängerung wird sichergestellt dass
die vereinbarkeit von pflege und beruf
weiter bestehen bleibt ein wichtiger
pfeiler unseres miteinander ist diese
vereinbarkeit und daher wird die
bundesregierung die regelungen im
pflegezeitgesetz und familien pflegezeit
über den 31 märz hinaus verlängern
[Applaus]
liebe bürgerinnen und bürger ich weiß
selber was es heißt als schicht
arbeiterin auf kurzarbeit zu sein
2008 habe ich selber kurzarbeitergeld
bezogen und ja ich und meine damaligen
kolleginnen und kollegen waren froh
diese großartige sicherung zu haben
der minister hat es eben angesprochen
kindergarten rucksack realpolitik sind
deutsche begriffe die den weg in die
englische sprache gefunden haben
gleiches galt für das wort kurzarbeit
dieses wort 20 eben gleich zu beginn der
pandemie und der dadurch entstandenen
wirtschaftlichen turbulenzen im
angloamerikanischen raum wieder dies
zeigt was für ein erfolg dieses
instrument zur bekämpfung von
arbeitslosigkeit ist es wurde
mittlerweile vielfach auf der welt
kopiert und ist neben der dualen
ausbildung ein absolutes erfolgsmodell
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
kurzarbeit hat vor einem 1 verhindert
massenarbeitslosigkeit der hochstand
wurde im sommer 2020 mit 6 millionen
beschäftigten erreicht und wir können
mit wissenschaftlichen background sagen
wir haben damit millionen jobs eben
erhalten
kolleginnen und kollegen die kritik am
schnellen verfahren kann ich teilweise
verstehen eine ausreichende
beratungszeit ist wichtig und dafür
stehen wir ja auch nur hier brauchen die
unternehmen und die beschäftigten
planungssicherheit
es ist eine nahtlose bewilligung von
kurzarbeitergeld eben hier notwendig wo
wir wofür wir den rechtlichen rahmen mit
der verlängerung setzten unser dank geht
ihm hier an durch sachverständige die an
die sachverständigen die ihre expertise
eingebracht haben und an die fraktionen
damit wir die schnell auf den weg
bringen können es pressiert
und weil es pressiert verlängern wie ein
bewährtes bestehendes instrument machen
kein neues thema auch und deshalb das
schnelle verfahren
es wird die maximale bezugsdauer ab 28
monate verlängert dies war eben unter
anderem eine forderung die mich und sie
in mehreren zuschriften immer wieder
erreicht hat es bleibt auch bei den
vereinfachten zugangs erleichterungen
und mini jobs bleiben anrechnungsfrei
diese antworten brauchen die
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer und
wir liefern sie
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen
warum machen wir das hier waren
debattieren wir hier heute es sind die
menschen die uns verdeutlichen dass die
verlängerung des kurzarbeitergeldes
gebraucht wird es ist ein unterschied ob
jemand sagt ich bin arbeitslos oder ich
bin in kurzarbeit es ist ein unterschied
ob jemand sagt ich weiß nicht wie es
machen soll oder ich kann pflege und
beruf vereinen es geht um harald sabine
jahre
jopie und gitte es geht um menschen und
die haben nahmen deshalb verlängern wir
das kurzarbeitergeld nicht bedanke mich
während
[Applaus]
hätten
das wäre natürlich interessant ob sie
bei diesem namen an
persönliche bekannte gedacht hat sie
sich aus wie
gerrit hui spricht als nächste auch sie
ist wie die vorrednerin mitglied im
ausschuss für arbeit und soziales
die regierung will das kroner
kurzarbeitergeld noch einmal um drei
monate bis ende juni verlängert
warum war in deutschland immer noch der
pandemie status gilt und nach ansicht
der regierung wohl auch in drei monaten
noch gelten soll warum sonst diese
erstaunliche verlängerung es sind im
wesentlichen menschen im gastgewerbe
handel event und kulturbetrieb die wegen
2g und 3g in kurzarbeit sind fast eine
halbe million von ihnen schon über seit
zwei jahren viele sogar in kurzarbeit
null das heißt sie sind de facto
arbeitslos würde man die kurzarbeit
nicht mehr verlängern wäre schlagartig
eine beitrag million menschen offiziell
arbeitslos
zusätzlich zu den stand heute 2,5
millionen arbeitslosen oder wenn man
ehrlich zählt und die unterbeschäftigt
mit einrechnet sind es ja tatsächlich
3,2 millionen arbeitslosen das sind sehr
sehr viele menschen die fast alle
arbeiten wollen aber nicht können weil
es keine arbeit für sie gibt und
es werden noch mehr werden so sehr sich
die regierung auch gemüt dies durch
gesetze zu verschleiern denn gesetze
schaffen keine arbeit nur die wirtschaft
als unternehmen und selbstständige
schaffen arbeit dies wird ihnen aber
extrem erschwert durch die pandemischen
gerne lungs maßnahmen oder haben sie
angst meine damen und herren von der
regierungskoalition
dass sie ohne pandemie verlängerung ihre
impfpflicht nicht mehr argumentieren
können ihre planungen
die von ihnen als ungeimpfte
stigmatisierten menschen wollen aber
nicht geimpft werden sie gehen seit
wochen zu hunderttausenden über die auf
die straße übrigens zusammen mit vielen
geimpften um ihnen genau das zu zeigen
und sie wollen sie trotzdem wird eine
impfung schwimmen warum den pandemie
verläuft können sie damit nicht ändern
aber sie ruinieren damit sehenden auges
unsere wirtschaft
wären überall in den ländern um uns
herum geöffnet und gelockert würden
bleiben sie mit ihrer impfpflicht
planung weiter auf deister fahrer
das ergebnis während überall um uns
herum die wirtschaft wieder wächst ist
sie in deutschland im letzten quartal
und fach ein ganzes prozent geschrumpft
die reallöhne sind ebenfalls gesunken
wenn sie diesen weg weitergehen fahren
die deutschland in die rezession
daher fordere ich sie auf beenden sie
endlich den panini status schaffen sie
alle regelungen ab und lassen sie die
wirtschaft wieder masken frei laufen das
erspart nicht nur den sozialkassen
kurzarbeiter kosten sondern sie geben
den menschen auch ein positives signal
und sagen ihnen ihr könnt wieder euren
berufen nachgehen ihr könnt alle
geschäfte wieder unbegrenzt betreiben
euch wieder unbegrenzt miteinander
treffen vergnügen und wieder ein ganz
normales leben führen nach euren
persönlichen geschmack
von kollegin puma gerieten sie alle hier
vertreten die bürger unseres landes
geben sie ihnen endlich ihre freiheit
zurück danke
der tunnel war das für die fdp fraktion
hat hier ein geisterfahrer kurs
kritisiert auch sie führten pascal kober
der sprecher für arbeitsmarkt- und
sozialpolitik der fdp fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wir freuen uns
dass wir die verlängerung der
sonderregelung beim kurzarbeitergeld
beschließen können wenn ich mich
ausdrücklich bedanken bei den
kolleginnen und kollegen der fraktionen
cdu/csu und linke dass sie den frist
verzichten zugestimmt haben dass sie
konstruktiv hiermit die regelungen
schnell auf den weg gebracht haben das
zeigt dass unser parlament
reaktionsschnell ist das zeigt dass
unser parallel parlamentarismus auch in
kürze handlungsfähig ist ein gutes
zeichen dafür möchte ich mich
ausdrücklich bedanken
die der verlängerung beschreiben wir
letztlich mehrere perspektiven zum einen
die wirtschaftliche lage und die
situation auf dem arbeitsmarkt haben
sich spürbar verbessert
das ist gut aber noch nicht für alle
betriebe und branchen gleichermaßen bei
der reihe von unternehmen hat sich in
den letzten wochen abgezeichnet dass sie
noch über den 31
märz sie daraus auch das
kurzarbeitergeld angewiesen sein werden
insbesondere die verantwort anstaltung
branche und die gastwirtschaft kämpfen
mit den auswirkungen und der ausbreitung
von omikron und mit der tatsache dass
die impfquote weiterhin hinter dem
wünschenswerten zurückbleibt für diese
unternehmen sind heute zu beschließenden
verlängerungen der möglichkeiten des
erleichterten zugangs zum
kurzarbeitergeld die chance
unverzichtbare mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter zu halten
dass die unternehmen in not sind ist
nicht ihre verantwortung sondern den
einschränkenden staatlichen maßnahmen
geschuldet und an der stelle möchte ich
mich auch ganz ausdrücklich einmal bei
den unternehmerinnen unternehmen
bedanken die über das kurzarbeitergeld
hinaus durch eigene leistungen den
sogenannten remanenzkosten
die solidarität mit ihren mitarbeitern
und mitarbeiter mitgetragen haben das
war ein tolles signal und dafür
ausdrücklichen dank von dieser stelle
aus
gleichzeitig wollen wir auch
perspektivisch aus dem krisenmodus auch
aussteigen und zur normalität wieder
zurückkehren das betrifft natürlich die
einschränkungen den maßnahmen die wir
zurücknehmen wollen und das betrifft
aber auch mittelfristig die sonne
regelungen zur kurzarbeit aus diesen
müssen wir in absehbarer zeit
verantwortungs bus wieder herauskommen
wir haben jetzt noch einmal um drei
monate verlängert mit der option einer
weiteren verlängerung durch eine
verordnungsermächtigung
aber die bundesregierung sollte dieses
mittel äußerst verantwortungsbewusst
einsetzen kurzarbeit darf und kann kein
dauer instrument sein wir müssen
vermeiden dass strukturelle probleme
einer branche durch das kurzarbeitergeld
verdeckt werden und das notwendige
anpassungen nicht zukunftsfähige
unternehmen
verbleiben
wir müssen zur kenntnis nehmen dass
viele unternehmen derzeit auch im
aufwachsen begriffen sind und
händeringend mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter suchen und dass der verbleib
in dem einen unternehmen für den
einzelnen durchaus sicherheit bedeutet
und erstrebenswert ist in manchen fällen
aber auch damit ein nachteil für ein
anderes unternehmen einher geht und
vielleicht eine chance für den einzelnen
mittelfristig verloren geht deshalb
müssen wir daran denken dass kurzarbeit
kein dauer instrument sein kann wir
müssen da auch daran denken dass die
ausgaben für das kurzarbeitergeld
finanziert werden müssen für die zukunft
glaube ich dass wir lernen müssen dass
die qualifizierung nicht in dem maße
stattgefunden hat wie wir es für gut
befunden hätten und dass wir daraus für
die zukunft lernen müssen wenn wir
kurzarbeit mit qualifizierung gemeinsam
verbinden wollen was muss besser werden
in zukunft das bleibt eine aufgabe aus
diesen erfahrungen und auch denen
sollten wir uns stellen
das kurzarbeitergeld ist eine
erfolgsgeschichte
aber nichts ist so gut dass es nicht
auch noch verbessert werden könnte
vielen dank liebe kolleginnen und eben
als nächstes steht für die fraktion die
linke
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
es ist absolut notwendig dass wir heute
die korona bedingten sonderregelung zur
kurzarbeit nochmals verlängern die linke
wird dem gesetzentwurf zustimmen die
beschäftigten müssen sich auf die volle
rückendeckung des parlaments verlassen
können
trotzdem es nervt ohne ende dass das
gesetz auf den letzten drücker ins
parlament kommt und dass dann noch nicht
mal die offensichtlichen mängel behoben
werden die lage ist doch die die
kurzarbeiter rinnen und kurzarbeiter
verzichten zwangsweise auf einkommen
gleichzeitig wird so vieles während der
inflation teurer das ist ein
riesenproblem für viele deshalb bleibt
die linke auch dabei erhöhen sie das
kurzarbeitergeld für die dauer der
pandemie auf 90 prozent führen sie
endlich ein mindestbußgeld von
1200 euro für vollzeitkräfte 1 das ist
doch viel besser als die leute noch
zusätzliche die jobcenter zu schicken
weil das kurzarbeitergeld vorne und
hinten nicht reicht um über die runden
zu kommen
minister heil ist ist wirklich ein
fatales signal was sie an die
leiharbeiterinnen und leiharbeiter
schicken dass sie kein kurzarbeitergeld
mehr erhalten sondern gerade
leiharbeiterinnen und leiharbeiter
befinden sich in permanent unsicheren
arbeitsverhältnisse nun dass sie jetzt
auch noch beim kurzarbeitergeld zu
beschäftigten zweiter klasse degradiert
werden also das finde ich wirklich
schäbig und dass das sogar die union
kritisiert also das sollte ihn als
sozialdemokrat wirklich zu denken geben
nicht zuletzt halte ich es für unklug
dass sie die übernahme von
sozialversicherungsbeiträgen
für alle unternehmen gleichermaßen
streichen wollen sie provozieren für
kleinere betriebe sie gerade echt
schlecht dastehen das aus und für ihre
beschäftigten die kündigung stattdessen
sollten die
finanzielle hilfen doch endlich an
bedingungen geknüpft werden genau das
haben sie von anfang an versäumt bisher
haben sie die kohle den unternehmen in
den rachen geworfen die gleichzeitig vor
ende dividenden manager-boni ausgezahlt
haben und jetzt sollen notleidende und
kleine betriebe dafür die zeche zahlen
und das ist wirklich eine unterirdische
krisenpolitik
lernen sie endlich aus der vergangenheit
der letzten zwei jahre und handeln sie
endlich entsprechend
jessica partie hatte
bundesarbeitsminister hubertus heil auch
direkt angesprochen der von der
regierungsbank der debatte noch bei
wohnt direkt danach wird ja dann auch
über den gesetzentwurf der
koalitionsfraktionen
abgestimmt und die linksfraktion hat
einen entschließungsantrag dazu sie auch
eingereicht deshalb spricht jetzt für
die spd fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich freue
mich dass ich meine erste rede hier zu
einem so wichtigen thema für die
arbeitnehmer und arbeitnehmern ihren
familien unserem land halten kann ich
komme aus dortmund und bei uns in
dortmund wissen die menschen sehr gut
was kurzarbeit bedeutet sie kennen es
aus zeiten des strukturwandels im
ruhrgebiet beim ende des bergbaus den
60er jahren oder in der stadt wieder
70er und das parlament glaube ich
sollten wir auch einmal einen blick
darauf werfen dass das für jeden
individuell erstmalig gut ist es ist
nicht schön in kurzarbeit zu müssen und
ja es bedeutet finanzielle einbußen aber
die menschen unserem land wissen auch es
rettet arbeitsplätze das hat die
mentalität unserer region das ruhrgebiet
die sozialdemokratische partei
deutschlands und auch nicht geprägt wer
hart arbeitet der wird in schwierigen
zeiten nicht alleine gelassen und dafür
stehen sozialdemokrat sozialdemokraten
und
es ist diese gewissheit über die wir
heute bei der verlängerung der
sonderregelung zum kurzarbeitergeld
abstimmen ein instrument ist auf dem
höhepunkt der pandemie circa sechs
millionen menschen und familien unserem
land sicherheit und stabilität gegeben
hat es ist fakt die pandemie ist noch
nicht vorbei in allen bundesländern
gelten noch immer infektionsschutz
maßnahmen hotels und gastronomie die
veranstaltungsbranche alle die beteiligt
sind wenn die kirmes in die stadt kommt
oder konzerte und festivals an stehen
alle diese menschen können noch immer
nicht in vollem umfang ihrer arbeit
nachgehen das bedeutet der grund aus dem
am 13 märz 2020 die verbesserung des
kurzarbeitergelds beschlossen wurde
besteht weiterhin und wie es damals
richtig und notwendig war die regeln zu
beschließen so ist jetzt auch jetzt
richtig und notwendig sind verlängern
aber
ebenso wie die infektion schutzmaßnahmen
der pandemie angepasst werden so passen
wir auch diese sonderregelung des
kurzarbeitergeldes der aktuellen
situation an deshalb verlängern wir eben
nicht eins zu eins die pandemie bedingt
der erstattung der
sozialversicherungsbeiträge zu 50
prozent lassen wir auslaufen
damit erhöhen wir den anreiz für
unternehmen ihre beschäftigten
weiterzubilden das hätte von anfang an
passieren soll wenn wir jetzt auf diese
50 prozent haben möchte der muss
weiterbilden wir haben von anfang an auf
weiterbildung gesetzt weil das hilft den
menschen und somit die
beschäftigungsbrücke auch eine
weiterbildungs brücke und hilft den
menschen beim beruflichen fortkommen
und ja es ist klar
es ist klar kurzarbeitergeld darf und
soll kein dauer instrument werden und es
muss irgendwann enden sowie hoffentlich
auch die pandemie bald enden wird wie
wir jetzt öffnung schritte diskutieren
sind auch unsere anpassungen erster
schritt zur rückkehr zu normalen
kurzarbeitergeld zur normalität deshalb
haben wir auch die leiharbeit aus den
sonderregeln rausgenommen weil 200.000
offene stellen bundesweit in der
leiharbeit das nicht mehr rechtfertigen
diese krisenregelung aber einst auch
klar und das wissen wir sehr genau ein
zu frühes ende des kurzarbeitergeldes
würde alles bisher erreichte gefährden
auf 24 monate kurzarbeitergeld würde
seine arbeitslosigkeit folgen und wie
bei einer echten brücke ist klar man
baut sie nicht zu lang aber auf keinem
verbaut man hier zu kurz sonst würden
die menschen hinten runter fallen und
das ist gegen die grundüberzeugung der
spd wir lassen niemanden hinten
runterfallen
aber wenn ich jetzt
einmal kurz auch nochmal auf die
änderungsanträge der opposition schaue
auf dem wortbeitrag von der strecke dann
fällt auf noch etwas hat sich seit 2000
20 geändert nicht nur der verlauf der
pandemie sondern früher sagt die cdu
noch in der regierung und ich möchte
daran erinnern da haben sie bei diesem
instrument gebremst
das haben sie getan und heute suchen sie
verzweifelt ihre rolle in der opposition
und stellen populistische
maximalforderung die vom geschehen auf
dem arbeitsmarkt pony die komplett
entkoppelt sind
sie haben und unter einem brink auf eine
konstruktive oppositionsarbeit
versprochen am dienstag haben sie am
märz situations vorsitzenden gewählt und
ich sage ihnen kaum hat der hand dreimal
gewählt da gekräht schon sind sie
wortbrüchig geworden weil das nicht
konstruktiv und dieser herr merkt den
fraktionsvorsitz gefehlt haben hat
damals bei der einführung besondere noch
gesagt das würde menschen von der arbeit
entwöhnen und das was sie hier tun nimmt
ihm niemand ab
das sechste mal dass gibt kurzarbeit und
so massiv eingesetzt haben war 2009 auf
dem höhepunkt der finanzkrise
damals hat das kurzarbeitergeld etwa 1,2
millionen menschen und ihre familien
durch die krise gebracht im anschluss
folgte das was die presse auch die
internationale presse als das deutsche
jobwunder bezeichnete damals sollte
übrigens arbeitsminister heute ist olaf
scholz bundesminister bundeskanzler und
das versichere ich ihnen will das auch
heute niemanden im stich eine rückkehr
zur normalität scheint nah damit das
klappt verlängern deuten diese maßnahmen
ein zweiter jobwunders dann hoffentlich
möglich deswegen bitten wir um
zustimmung herzlichen dank
denkbar dass die spd-fraktion und
willkommen zur letzten rednerin bevor
über die verlängerung der sonderregelung
beim kurzarbeitergeld abgestimmt wird
und das ist ja ne schimke die für die
cdu csu fraktion im ausschuss für arbeit
und soziales sitzt und auch vorsitzende
des tourismusausschusses ist meine damen
und herren ich habe heute hier das
politische schlusswort in dieser debatte
und ich empfehle in diesem zusammenhang
der bundesregierung doch etwas mehr
praxisnähe drei der entscheidung über
künftige gesetzgebungsverfahren die
union kritisiert zu recht dass in der
aktuellen in der zukünftigen
kurzarbeitergeldregelung die erstattung
der sv beiträge rausgenommen ist die
zeitarbeit auch ausgeschlossen wird und
meine damen und herren ich will ihn
eines sagen es ist ja gut dass wir im
märz endlich wieder loslegen können und
dass wir wieder öffnen aber unsere
unternehmen brauchen zwei bis drei
monate mindestens vorlaufzeit die
brauchen planungszeit glauben sie denn
im ernst dass im märz schönes zimmer
gebucht und bezahlt ist glauben sie denn
im ernst dass im märz schon die gewerke
beauftragt sind die bühne gebaut das
material beschafft ist glauben sie denn
im ernst dass im märz schon die tickets
verkauft und bezahlt sind das ist nicht
der fall meine damen und herren genau
das ist der punkt was wir meinen die
liquidität in unseren unternehmen fehlt
die war anfangs noch da da hat man noch
die eigenen gelder zusammengekratzt das
eigenkapital davon versucht in die krise
rüber zu kommen das zu durchstehen aber
jetzt sind die kassen leer es ist kein
polster mehr da und deshalb sagen wir
auch als union als ordnungspolitische
kraft in diesem land dass wir uns gut
überlegen müssen wie wir solche hilfen
solche unterstützungsleistungen solche
existenziellen dinge die wir da haben
die auch erfolgversprechend sind künftig
ausgestaltet und auch der tourismus ist
massiv betroffen nach auch wenn das
hotelzimmer gebucht es machen wir uns
nichts vor wir haben es immer noch auch
im ausland mit unterschiedlichen
pandemischen regelungen zu tun nicht
überall ist jeder impfstoff akzeptiert
überall gibt es unterschiedliche
quarantäne regelungen das alles trifft
auf unsere branche in deutschland das
trifft auf die unternehmen und ich
empfehle ihnen sehr kommen sie doch mal
raus aus ihren bürokratischen setzen und
unterhalten sie sich mal mit den
menschen in diesem land mit den branchen
in diesem land mit den unternehmen an in
unserem land dann wissen sie wie die
lage draußen ist und ich gebe dem dgb
recht das mache ich nicht oft aber ich
gebe den dgb recht der zu recht
kritisiert dass die herausnahme der
zeitarbeit ein schwerwiegender fehler
ist weil sie unbedingt erforderlich ist
die zeitarbeit weiter zu unterstützen da
uns sonst in diesem bereich eine
entlassungswelle droht meine damen und
herren das lieferketten problem in
unserem auf unserer welt ist immer noch
nicht überstanden im gegenteil im herbst
ohne weitere einbußen 37 prozent der
menschen die im bereich von lieferketten
tätig sind sind zeit arbeitnehmerinnen
und arbeitnehmer und meine damen und
herren es trifft die schwächsten denn 34
prozent aller arbeiten den geflüchteten
sind in der zeitarbeit tätig 20 prozent
aller ehemaligen langzeitarbeitslosen
arbeiten in der zeitarbeit so und
deswegen ich bin der meinung dass das
was in § 11 arbeit nehmen elf
arbeitnehmerüberlassungsgesetz steht das
unter außergewöhnlichen verhältnissen
die weitere unterstützung der zeitarbeit
gerechtfertigt ist dass sich daran nach
wie vor nichts geändert hat natürlich
muss die zeitarbeit weiter unterstützt
werden und zu sagen naja 5600 anträge im
monat januar ist doch nicht so viel die
brauchen das nicht mehr ich finde das
ist eine menge und diese menschen
brauchen weiterhin unsere unterstützung
meine damen und herren
meine damen es geht darum es geht nicht
nur darum jetzt wieder aufzumachen es
geht darum unsere unternehmen auf den
letzten metern der pandemie nicht noch
das genick zu brechen deswegen
appelliere ich an sie unterstützen sie
unseren antrag und stellen sie für die
weitere unterstützung der zeitarbeit und
auch die erstattung der sozialbeiträge
vielen dank
ich diese die aussprache und wir kommen
zur abstimmung über den von den
fraktionen spd bündnis 90 die grünen fdp
eingebrachten gesetzentwurf zur
verlängerung der sonderregelungen im
zusammenhang mit der chor mit 19 konnte
die pandemie beim kurzarbeitergeld und
anderen leistungen der ausschuss für
soziales und arbeit empfiehlt in seiner
beschlussempfehlung auf drucksache 734
den gesetzentwurf der fraktionen von spd
bündnis 90 die grünen fdp auf drucksache
688 in der ausschuss fassung anzunehmen
wer dem gesetzentwurf in der ausschuss
fassung zustimmen bilden und die bitte
ich um das handzeichen
hier stimmt dagegen wäre enthält sich
damit ist der gesetzentwurf in zweiter
beratung angenommen bei enthaltung der
fdp fraktion und zustimmung aller
anderen fraktionen drittelpause und so
selbst welche mir jetzt die dritte
beratung und schlussabstimmung ebenso
ausfällt dass diese sonderregelung
verlängert werden bis zum 30
herzlichen dank damit ist der
gesetzentwurf in dritter beratung und
schlussabstimmung angenommen mit dem
gleichen stimmenverhältnis wie vorher
wir kommen nun mal das gibt noch einen
entschließungsantrag von der
linksfraktion
das wurde hier auch schon diskutiert